unser thema hartz 4 kürzen ist das
gerecht das bundesverfassungsgericht in
karlsruhe hat heute entschieden
teilweise ist das schon in ordnung so
verfassungsrechtlich teilweise aber auch
nicht also so wie bislang ist es nicht
okay in ihrer jetzigen form sind die
hartz4 kürzungen also die sanktionen
teilweise verfassungswidrig
wir sprechen darüber mit helena stein
haus sie ist gründerin und
geschäftsführerin von sanktionsfrei und
vertritt dabei die interessen von hartz
4 empfängern sie kennt das gefühl hat
hier zu beziehen aus eigener erfahrungen
sowohl als jugendliche als tochter einer
alleinerziehenden mutter aber auch
später als erwachsene ist sie mit diesem
thema konfrontiert worden
und sie sagt diese erfahrungen prägen
sie bis heute hallo frau steinhaus mit
welchem gefühl haben sie dann das urteil
heute vormittag in karlsruhe so zur
kenntnis genommen also ich war
tatsächlich positiv überrascht ich habe
mich total gefreut weil ich einfach
nicht damit gerechnet habe dass ja dass
die sanktion insoweit angetastet also
abgeschafft werden
aber gleichzeitig also es ist sozusagen
ein weinendes und ein lachendes auge
weil natürlich sind 30 prozent
sanktionen immer noch 30 prozent so viel
nichtsdestotrotz ist ein riesenerfolg
und ja den können wir auch feiern wir
sprechen gleich weiter frau steinhaus
über sie auch und ihre arbeit ganz
besonders wir wollen aber euch natürlich
vorher auch noch mal ein überblick
darüber geben was heute in karlsruhe
genau entschieden worden ist welche
kürzungen weiter gehen können und welche
nicht und wähnen das ganze auch betrifft
und darüber berichtet günter neufeld die
volle härte der sanktionen yogalehrer
bendel bekam sie zu spüren vor jahren
geriet er in eine seelische krise wurde
depressiv reagierte nicht mehr auf
kontaktversuche des jobcenters
irgendwann floss kein geld mehr
das bedeutet dass man freunde nicht mehr
besuchen kann das ganze sozialleben
leidet darunter
man fühlt sich ausgeschlossen ja
abgewertet vielleicht auch durch den
staat abgewertet jedoch soll sich
niemand fühlen die menschenwürde müsse
gewahrt bleiben sagt das
bundesverfassungsgericht
doch das sei bei den ganz harten
sanktionen nicht der fall
grundsätzlich jedoch dürfe der staat
menschen denen er helfe auch pflichten
auferlegen er kann sich auch dafür
entscheiden die verletzung dieser
pflichten zu sanktionieren in dem
leistungen vorübergehend gemindert
werden ein alleinstehender hartz 4
empfänger hat monatlich im schnitt rund
800 euro
bisher galt lehnte er einen zumutbaren
job ab verlor er 127 beim zweiten mal
innerhalb eines jahres 254 euro
beim dritten mal gab es kein geld mehr
alles befristet auf drei monate
doch gar keine zahlungen das geht zu
weit sagt das gericht und auch die
sanktion nach der zweiten ablehnung sei
zu hart zulässig bleibt der abzug der
bisher nach der ersten ablehnung fällig
war
kleine sanktionen also sind weiterhin
rechtmäßig die harten kürzungen aber
entfallen mit sofortiger wirkung
es fühlt sich nicht so stark auf unser
geschäft auswirken weil die große große
anzahl der menschen die zu uns kommen
die wollen auch ihre arbeitslosigkeit
beenden die arbeiten auch mit die sind
kooperativ ist die sonne geht es um
diejenigen die zum zweiten oder zum
dritten mal eine arbeit auf ablehnen und
das ist der sehr sehr sehr geringe teil
der menschen die wir kürzen müssen hartz
4 empfänger bendel fühlt sich vom
bundesverfassungsgericht verstanden
die gesellschaft wird damit von angst
auf inklusion umgestellt den leuten wird
nicht ein stock in die speichen ihres
lebens gesteckt und deswegen bin ich
sehr positiv überrascht das ist heute
ein urteil in die richtige richtung
gehört wie der staat künftig auf
wiederholte verweigerungen reagieren
soll
dazu muss die politik sich jetzt neue
regeln ausdenken und wir sprechen weiter
mit helena stein haus geschäftsführerin
von sanktionsfrei frau stein aus bevor
wir dann gleich wieder auf das urteil zu
sprechen kommen vielleicht erklären sie
noch mal ganz kurz was sie machen
sanktionsfrei was ist das und was machen
sie genau genau sanktions preis ein
verein der sich für eine bedingungslose
grundsicherung einsetzt und das tun wir
praktisch indem der hartz4 sanktionen
finanziell ausgleichen
jeder kann über unsere website
sanktionsfrei punkt.de automatisch
widerspruch einreichen gegen sanktionen
und dann bekommt er auch kontakt zu
unseren anwälten wir gleichen das geld
aus
und ja grundsätzlich ist das eben ein
standbein die einzelfallhilfe aber im
grunde ist ein zweiter sehr sehr
wichtiger faktor die
öffentlichkeitsarbeit also das thema
sanktionen und hat vier zu
entstigmatisieren und letztendlich auch
aufmerksamkeit darauf zu lenken
sie haben mir im vorgespräch gesagt dass
sie persönlich in ihrem leben auch schon
mehrere male mit hartz4 zu tun hatten
auch schon mit sanktionen also mit
kürzungen
welche erfahrungen haben sie da gemacht
naja ich war als hat vier eingeführt
wurde war ich noch in der schule und hat
bei meiner mutter gelebt die war eine
zeit lang arbeitslos und wurde dann auch
sanktioniert wird weil sie einen termin
verpasst hatte und da sowieso viel zu
wenig zum leben war war es einfach nur
noch weniger das war ja einfach im
grunde für sie nicht tragbar eine super
schwierige situation
und ich habe auch nach dem studium
hartz4 bekommen habe auch einen termin
verpasst und hatte diese zehn prozent
sanktionen das war für mich in dem
moment mehr oder weniger okay weil ich
nicht lange von hartz iv gelebt haben
also und ich war alleinstehend ich habe
keine komplexe situation gehabt aber
trotzdem habe ich mich immer gefühlt in
der kommunikation dem jobcenter als
würde ich etwas falsch machen waren ja
auch immer in jedem brief eigentlich
sofort eine sanktions androhung mit
geschickt wurde und das ist der standard
dann kommen noch mal zurück zu dem
urteil von heute jetzt muss man ja dazu
sagen das betrifft ja nun nicht allzu
viele die jetzt also von diesen sehr
hohen sanktionen betroffen waren also 60
prozent und mehr die es ja jetzt dann
nicht mehr geben darf von einem prozent
kann man da ungefähr sprechen welche
relevanz hat dann dieses urteil trotzdem
für sie ich weiß gar nicht woher sie
diese ein prozent nehmen ich kenne die
zahl nicht alles kann sein
trotzdem hat es immer sehr sehr viele
menschen tatsächlich betroffen weil
selbst hinter einem prozent stehen ja
echte menschen leben und schicksale und
wir haben bei sanktionsfreie sehr sehr
viele menschen gehabt die zu 100% zu 60
prozent sanktioniert wurden deren kosten
der unterkunft gekürzt wurden und die
ihre wohnung verloren haben
insofern macht das natürlich für diese
menschen riesenunterschied und es ist
auch für alle anderen mehr
natürlich schon meine erleichterung zu
wissen dass es nicht soweit überhaupt
kommen kann
insofern hat das urteil natürlich ein
sehr sehr großen wert
es stellt auf einer art einen gewissen
also einen gewissen eine menschenwürde
wieder her und das sagt vor allem dass
wir 15 jahre lang gegen die verfassung
gehandelt haben und das finde ich schon
ein starkes stück dass es eigentlich der
das ist der skandal daran und ich würde
mir sehr wünschen dass wir überhaupt
auch den mut haben die sanktionen
vollständig abzuschaffen
also 7000 in absoluten zahlen sind die
quellen und sind die daten die wir jetzt
unseren quellen entnehmen konnten also
dass nur noch mal zur erläuterung
wenn sie jetzt sagen sie sind dafür oder
sie streben an dass sanktionen gänzlich
aufgegeben werden vielleicht noch mal
ganz grundsätzlich die frage was spricht
denn aus ihrer sicht gegen sanktionen
das grundprinzip fördern und fordern
gewesen die idee mit der einführung von
hartz 4
was spricht aus ihrer sicht dagegen dass
man leuten die nicht kooperieren auch
mit sanktionen droht also sanktionen
werden ja genutzt als motivator also um
menschen dazu zu motivieren sich
sozusagen also ihr leben in die hand zu
nehmen und sich um arbeit zu kümmern
und das funktioniert überhaupt gar nicht
also man bringt man motiviert die
menschen nicht sondern man versetzt sie
in angst und panik und in existenzangst
eigentlich normandie dann nehmen sie
vielleicht aus panik ein job mann der
aber vielleicht gar nicht zu ihm passt
ja und man spart auch kein geld durch
die sanktionen also nichts an den
sanktionen hat bisher funktioniert und
eigentlich ist ja diese drohkulisse die
dadurch aufgebaut wird vollkommen fehl
am platz weil menschen die in hartz4
sind sind normalerweise gerade in einer
umbruchsituation oder einer schweren
familiären situation oder sie sind
längerfristig krank oder sie pflegen
angehörige oder sind alleinerziehend
also diese menschen brauchen gerade
unterstützung und nicht eine drohkulisse
ein draw systemen für das man sich
schämt dass man teil davon ist aber
andererseits ist es ja nun auch so dass
wenn eben nicht kooperiert wird wenn
eben bestimmte angebote die gemacht
werden auch nicht angenommen werden
man ja auch vielleicht der allgemeinheit
gegenüber auch als staat eben die
verpflichtung verspürt also den
steuerzahler neben da auch die
rechenschaft schuldig ist das trotzdem
aufgepasst wird das also keinen ich sage
mal schindluder getrieben wird bzw
dass es eben nicht zu missbrauch kommt
also was würden sie vorschlagen
in welche richtung sollte der staat denn
da vorgehen
ja das verstehe ich die sorge ist
natürlich mal groß dass sozusagen das
system ausgenutzt wird
und das ist natürlich klar dass es auch
immer wieder menschen gibt die das tun
aber problematisch an hartz 4 ist dass
wir das gesamte system darauf
ausgerichtet haben eben diese zum diese
menschen zu fangen und dadurch stellen
wir alle unter generalverdacht
deswegen bin ich davon überzeugt dass
wir da komplett umschwenken müssen
und letztendlich bei den menschen
individueller gucken müssen wie können
wir sie denn erreichen wie bekommen wir
sie dazu zu uns zu kommen ein termin
wahrzunehmen angebote anzunehmen
vielleicht weiterbildung zu machen ich
glaube dass es sinnvoller als mit druck
zur arbeit mit strafe und ich sehe ein
dass das keine einfache aufgabe ist das
ist vollkommen klar
also sie würden das fördern gegenüber
dem fordern stärker betont ich würde
gerne noch unsere zuschauer bzw user mit
ins boot holen bei facebook schreibt uns
tom olvenstedter er sagt ungerechtes
urteil wer nichts für sein auskommen
leistet und nur von der gesellschaft
lebt sollte soweit sanktioniert werden
dass er nur noch gutscheine für seine
existenz bekommt wie gehabt das ist aber
nicht die einzige meinung es gibt bei
uns auch wirklich sehr kontroverse
diskussionsbeiträge michael schuh
schreibt hat hier beziehung war
erniedrigend und ich wurde in die
sinnlosesten maßnahmen gesteckt ich bin
gelernter grafiker und sollte sechs
monate in einer maßnahme basis
computerkurs ist klar schreibt er
das ist ja vielleicht noch ein anderes
thema wie weit sind die maßnahmen die
ergriffen werden auch also die forderung
beziehungsweise förderung in dem fall
inwieweit sind die dann auch immer
sinnvoll ihrer erfahrung nach ja da sind
total wichtiger punkt dass es ja auch
mit ein grund weswegen sanktionen
ergehen weil menschen sich dafür
entscheiden eine weiterbildung zum
beispiel nicht fortzuführen oder gar
nicht erst anzutreten weil sie eben
überhaupt nicht in qualifikation
entsprechen und
dann nimmt man das vielleicht auch im
chaos der sanktionen weil man eben nicht
jeden tag acht stunden lang über monate
bewerbungsschreiben will obwohl man es
schon kann oder eben wie dieser grafiker
diese erfahrung machen möchte
das kann ich schon nachvollziehen und
deswegen ist es eigentlich so wichtig
hartz4 sanktionsfrei zu machen weil das
gibt den menschen die freiheit nein zu
sagen und die ist ganz ganz wichtig also
diese mündigkeit verstehe natürlich ist
es jetzt in unserem fall dann auch noch
mal interessant die in anführungszeichen
gegenseite zu wort kommen zu lassen in
diesem fall ingo zielonkowsky er ist
geschäftsführer des jobcenters in
düsseldorf also einer von denen die hin
und wieder auch mal sanktionen dann
tatsächlich aussprechen müssen und er
hat natürlich auch eine meinung zu dem
heutigen urteil und da hören wir mal
rein ich dann natürlich heute nach dem
urteil sagen dass wir da natürlich
bestätigt sind dass das urteil
festgelegt dass eine leistungskürzung
verfassungsgemäß ist und wer schon
feststellen dass wir ja doch viele
menschen auch durch einen kleinen
schubser oder durch eine kleine
aufmerksamkeit auch tatsächlich wieder
dazu bewegen können wenn sie den weg zu
gehen um sich den regeln anzupassen
wir sehen natürlich auch negatives thema
dabei aber ich glaube die mehrzahl der
menschen will auch arbeiten und soll
auch arbeiten und braucht dazu aber
unsere unterstützung
also die mehrheit der menschen will
arbeiten und soll arbeiten ich denke das
deckt sich auch mit ihrem menschenbild
nun sagt er hin und wieder bräuchte man
mal einen an schubser warum hat er damit
unrecht wenn der anschutz bedeutet dass
man diesen mensch unter das
existenzminimum kürzt dann finde ich das
absolut falsch und es verstößt gegen die
menschenwürde
und ja insofern ist auch das urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichts leider nicht
ausreichend
aber wie schon gesagt zumindest wurde
bestätigt dass das über diese vielen
jahre lang gegen die verfassung
gehandelt wurde und ich hoffe dass wir
in ein paar jahren sagen können dass wir
auch diese sinnlosen 30% sanktionen die
jetzt noch erlaubt sind
abschaffen werden dann sagen sie doch
mal ganz konkret ihrer vorstellung nach
was würden sie machen stattdessen
ja ich würde hartz4 sanktionsfrei
auszahlen
und da gibt es dann aber auch noch viele
andere punkte die die verbessert werden
können zum einen die höhe des
regelsatzes
dann müssten die bedarfsgemeinschaften
aufgelöst werden
das schonvermögen müsse erhöht werden
also hat vier muss letztendlich nur form
annehmen
in der die menschen eine situation
bekommen aus der heraus sie ihr
potenzial entfalten können und auch sich
wieder in die gesellschaft dann
einbringen können dann wenn sie es eben
können es gibt ja auch zeiten in denen
man mal vielleicht gar nicht arbeiten
konnten
nicht jeder kann immer arbeiten das ist
einfach so und ja die meisten hartz 4
beziehen wollen arbeiten viele arbeiten
aber sogar die idee hinter hat hier also
der zusammenlegung von arbeits und
sozialverhaltens schon auch dass man
gesagt hat man möchte die menschen
möglichst schnell wieder in arbeit
bringen und wenn man sich jetzt die
arbeitslosenzahlen anguckt also die
statistik sich anschaut muss man ja
sagen die zahlen sind schon stark
zurückgegangen also man hat jetzt
deutlich weniger arbeitslose als zu
beginn der einführung 2005 muss man
nicht sagen dann ist dieses konzept
vielleicht doch aufgegangen was würden
sie dem entgegenhalten
ja so die zahlen stimmen ja nicht ganz
es werden ja alle menschen die in
maßnahmen sich befinden und in ein euro
jobs werden aus den statistiken
herausgerechnet
das heißt also man 2,3 millionen etwa
liegt momentan die offizielle
arbeitslosenzahl in deutschland genau
sind aber eher so 6 millionen weil da
dazu gehören auch noch kinder und
jugendliche und und eben menschen die
sich in maßnahmen befinden und so weiter
also ja und abgesehen davon ja
vielleicht bringt man manchmal die
menschen schneller in arbeit aber ich
langfristig funktioniert das überhaupt
nicht und wenn dieses system dazu führt
dass menschen arbeiten annehmen die
unterhalb ihrer qualifikation liegen und
damit sozusagen die ganze zukunft
ruiniert ist und vielleicht die auch so
schlecht bezahlt sind dass die rente
hinterher total gering ausfällt und
alles zwangsläufig in altersarmut führt
dann würde ich nicht sehen wo das ein
erfolg ist
ihr verein sanktionsfreie setzt sich für
ein bedingungsloses grundeinkommen ein
also über das für und wider des
bedingungslosen grundeinkommens muss ja
auch verschiedene modelle gibt da könnte
man eine ganze sendung noch mal darüber
machen was würden sie sich dann ganz
konkret gefragt von einem systemwechsel
hin zu diesem grundeinkommen versprechen
ja ich würde mir versprechen dass eben
viele menschen die sich in
existenzieller not befinden endlich da
rauskommen und dadurch sich auch mit
etwas anderem beschäftigen können als
mit diesem ständigen überlebenskampf ja
ich glaube dass das viele potenziale
freisetzen kann die wir noch gar nicht
die wir noch gar nicht voraussehen
können deswegen kann ich mir vorstellen
dass es zumindest sinn macht das mal
auszuprobieren weil hartz 4 ist mehr
oder weniger gescheitert ich glaube das
ist auch gar kein geheimnis mehr
kritiker auch unter anderem ja
interessanterweise gewerkschaften nennen
das bedingungslose grundeinkommen oft so
eine art stille halteprämie also da gibt
es also auch große gesellschaftliche
widerstände ist denn die zeit schon reif
dafür
ihrer meinung nach oder um es auch mit
den worten unseres users mario bitte
tage zu formulieren was meint elena wie
lange es dauern wird bis das
bedingungslose grundeinkommen kommt ich
wünschte ich könnte das voraussehen
aber ich habe keine ahnung ehrlich
gesagt deswegen machen wir bei
sanktionsfreie diesen realpolitischen
ansatz dass wir sagen wir gleich vier
sanktionen aus und damit es zumindest
das existenzminimum nicht mehr kürzen
wir setzen uns dafür ein
einfach weil wir versuchen schritt für
schritt in diese richtung zu gehen und
ja wie lange es tatsächlich noch da war
oder ob es tatsächlich irgendwann
passiert ich wage es nicht vorauszusagen
wir sind jedenfalls dabei wenn es soweit
ist ganz lieben dank das ist ein
spannendes thema das gut ankommen ich
habe es gerade schon gesagt da könnte
man noch mal eine ganz eigene sendung zu
machen also dieses feld konnten wir
heute nur teilweise bankern das war das
gespräch mit helena stein aus vielen
dank gründerin und geschäftsführerin von
sanktionsfrei und euch ganz lieben dank
für die aufmerksamkeit heute hier bei
unserem live stream der nächste live
stream ganz klar wieder am donnerstag
dann allerdings sogar schon um
18 uhr tschüss euch einen schönen abend
und bis bald
und wenn euch dieser live-stream
gefallen hat dann gefallen euch
vielleicht auch noch weitere streams die
wir hier oder themen die wir hier im
angebot haben zum beispiel wie ihr es
als arbeiter kind an die uni schafft das
seht ihr hier oder hintergründe zum
krieg in syrien das seht ihr dann dort
oder auch der zdf heute kanal den könnte
abonnieren und dann verpasst ihr auch
keinen live stream
das würde uns natürlich sehr freuen mehr
dazu hier